それは想像でもいいんですけど
我々の心っていうのは街のようなものであると
と見てください 街に例えた場合は
当然守るということになるんですね
戦わなくちゃいけないということになるんですね
お城を造って 周りにすごい壁を作ると
もうずっと考え方はもう徹底的に戦うという
で あの京都 神戸 ちょっと行ったところで何か有名なお城ありますね
愛媛城でしたっけ 姫路城
で あれも戦うという概念で造っているんですね
なんか歩いても中に入って歩いても歩いても歩いても歩いてもあのお城には辿らないんですよ
そんなにもう外国にあるような
ものすごい大きいというわけでもないんですけど
しかし そう簡単にはもうどんな形作ってればわからないんですけど
とにかくぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回されて
下へ行ったり また上がったり
また下りたりとかね ヘトヘト疲れるんですね
お城の真ん中のところに入る場合
その中でも で 外ではすごいかっこよく見えるんですけど
少しもうもう最悪やと思いますね
あの中の生活っていうのは
で 至る所でも隠れて戦う
隠れて戦うという概念で作ってるんですね
その中でこういうお偉い方々が住んでるんだからね
で 大変苦しいかなと思いますけどね
で 寝るところはないし
リラックスしてのんびりするところはないし
うーん でもこれはまた文化遺産があっていてね
で もう確かに外から見ると
どこからでも見られると
ものすごい美しい作品なんですね
中は地獄みたいなもの
地獄そのものを思わせる恐ろしい雰囲気なんです
気持ち悪いというともう並大抵のところじゃない
やはりお城に上がって上から街を見ても
あの美しさって何だと
と思われちゃうんですよ
だからもうこの日本のお城っていうのは
この街のミニチュアみたいなもんなんです
これはミニチュアと思っちゃえばね
小さいんだから どこらでも大きなものはないんですからね
まあ江戸城ぐらいかな
大きいといえば まあそちら人住んでるんだからね
まあそれなりに 楽に生活できるようにできていると思いますけど
昔はそんな贅沢はしなかったんですから
とにかくもう朝から晩までもう戦う概念で
人殺すことで考えていかなくちゃいけなかったんですね
それでずいぶん 幸福でいたでしょうね
ですからヨーデータマーランパンヤーブデーナ
だからお釈迦様はまた戦うという言葉を使ってヨーデータというのは戦いなさいと
誰と戦いなさいというのはマーレ
ヨーデータマーラン 悪魔と戦いなさいと
武器はパンヤーブデーナ
知恵という武器で戦いなさい
とパンヤーっていうのは知恵で
知恵という刀を持って悪魔と戦うと
ジタンはラッヘー で 買った
買っただけ 買ったものはちゃんと大事に守れと
アニヴェーサノーシア
そちらにはしかし執着するものはないんだと
ということで 勝ったならば執着するはずなんですけど
この場合は執着するものはないっていうことで
これっていうのはどういうことかと
やっぱりこれは瞑想というね
お釈迦様おっしゃってるこの瞑想修行方法
別に文学的な表現していることとね
まあ瞑想は真剣にやる人っていうのは体に価値は入れません
いわゆる真剣にやると言ったっても
何か結果成功する人は体に価値は入れません
体に価値を入れると それで俗世間の思考だから
仏教の世界には入ることはできないんです
ですから 瞑想する人っていうのは結構いますけどね
でもちょっと眠気が出たんだからって言ってやめる
お腹がすいたんだからってやめる
足が痛くなったんだからってやめる
ちょっと熱くなったんだからって
で やめるんですね やめるところじゃなくて
すごく怯えて震えるんです
時々 で 何でしょうかと
瞑想して体がちょっと熱くなったと
間違ってるんではないんでしょうかと
と聞かれたりする だからそれを私に聞いてはいけないんですよ
だって私が言ったやり方で瞑想して
体がちょっと熱くなって
これでとんでもなく驚いてびっくりして怖くなって
殺されるような感じで震えながらね
間違ってるんではないかと他の人に聞かなくちゃいけないんです
その場合は それで他の人は確かに間違ってる
こういう風にやってください
なんとか教えてくれるでしょうと思いますけどね
また ある人がちょっと体がなんかピリピリピリピリしたんだということで
もう震えているんです
瞑想間違ってるんだと
言ったのは私ですからね
そうするとそれ自体に私は失格でしょうしね
だから私に聞くんじゃないんで
そこら辺の誰かに聞いてみれば
だから そこでこの気功やって
指先とかね 体とかピリピリしちゃうとすごく喜んじゃう
すごく喜ぶだけじゃなくて
なんかもう神様になったつもりで
もう で ちょっと私でもちょっと何かちょっと今日は腰が痛いなと
じゃあもう直してあげるぞとかね
直してくれたこと一度もなかったんですけど
で それで私は素晴らしいですと
暖かくなったでしょうとかね
はいはいと って言わなくちゃいけないんです
難しいんですね 私にとっては
だって別な思考を持ってるんだから
他の普通の人だったらね
ものすごく暖かくなりましたよと
マインドコントロールですからね
そうなるんですけどね
私にとっては気持ち悪くて
こんな汚れてる人はね
体を触るなよと そういう嫌な気分出るんですよ
触るなよと 触れたくもないんだからね
ものすごくもう怪我立ってますよ
気持ち悪くて それで素晴らしい
暖かくてやっぱり柔らかく
早く言えるんです 私は
なんかすごく良くなりましたと
良くなったことは一度もないんです
で 針もやったことあります
別に私やりたくない 強引にやらせる
もうやるんだからね それでどうですかと
すごくいいんです 全然何のこともないんです
あまりにも強引 また変なことをやらせたら困るんだから
私は自分一人でも治してもらうんです
誰にも頼もしないで でなきゃものすごい
もう何されるか分からないんだから
何でもいいんですけども
体を触ることだけはもうやめてほしいというかね
で だからあの瞑想の場合は
この自分の体大事だと
宝物であると 壊れるものではないという
あの一般の世間の考え方で瞑想をすると
やっぱり進展というか
進歩っていうのはまあ可能性もない
それはもう明らかです
で それで面白いっていうのは
まあちょっと体 時々ピリピリするっていうことはね
まあそっち だから熱くはなりますよ
それは私は間違ってるとは分かりませんだけど
私の経験はそういうことなんです
で まあ私はまあもう汚れてる人は体触るのすごく嫌がりますけど
まあ子供なんかはまあ何のことなく平気なんですけど
で 子供なんかはまあ時々起きて体に乗っかったり一緒に寝たりはするんですけど
それものすごく嫌なんですけど
まあ子供だから何とも言えないし
我慢はしますけど なんかすごい暖房を抱いて寝たような感じなんです
そいつらはもう手足を伸ばしちゃって
もうすごい勝手に寝るんだから
そんな感じないかもしれませんだけど
あんまり体ジリジリジリ動かさない大人にしてみれば
もう結構大変な苦行なんです
もう全くもう暖房なんですよ
それぐらいもう子供の体でももう熱があるんですよ
だから人が人ぐらい多少で集めていると
もうかなり熱いと思いますけどね
これに驚いて触れるんだから
あーね ある人がね もうものすごく頑固と断ったんです
このスローではもう歩けないんだと
自分の体がものすごいもう弱いんだと
ものすごくまあ腰やら膝やら肩やらもう凍ってしまって
もう大変やと で 私はもう体が弱くて痛いんだったらね
もうマラソンとかね メートル走る人っていうのはいないと思いますけどね
だからものすごく早くやらないと
で その人とあちこちいろいろ他の用事があって一緒に行ったこともありますけど
もう歩けないんです 私はいてじーっと待っているんですね
そんな人にちょっとゆっくり歩いたらどうですか？と
頑固反対 逃げっこはないんです
元々もうもうもうおかしい体で歩けない
姿勢が悪い ゆっくり歩くと言ったら反対をする
では早く歩きなさいと言ったらできるわけでもない
やっぱりそういうふうにものすごい知識的に優れてるんです
だから私には理解できない思考をいっぱい持っているんです
まあなかなかもう もう異様ですよ
ただそこら辺に立て続けにはね
これ結構この社会で それでまあ
とにかく私よりは世間知ってるんだっていうことは
私に証拠を出す出たくて瞑想をやるんだと
それ一回だけで一回瞑想をやって
こちらの全部ばらしてやるぞというね
いかに私たちは間違っているのかと
それはすごいありがたいことでしょ
三十分瞑想したら まあなんだ仏教はっていう風に言える状態になりますからね
それで でははっきり言う通りにやってほしいと言って
スローモーションでやってくださいと言ったら
もう若い人なんですけど
もう八十歳のばあちゃんたちが大体背中が曲がっちゃうでしょ
年取ってくるとね 特に女性の場合はね
それで杖がないとね 歩けないし
で 腰から腰を全くも曲げて
ゆっくり歩くんです こんなの歩けるんですかね
ちょっと想像してください
この九十度に腰から体曲げてスローで歩くっていうことは
できるわけない それでまあブーブーブーでも歩くんですよ
私は背筋を伸ばしてくださいと言ったら
もうそれはやらない あえて曲げてやるんですね
だから そういう風にこのとにかく逆らってやるぞって
何のためかもわからないんですね
だから まあ世界一智慧のある人っていうね
まあすっごい自信があってね
それでも二足二はもう千四百八十八だよというぐらいの知識なんです
もう相手にすることできんっていう
で まあいろいろそれでもそれでももうもう嫌だったらやめればいいのに
あれこれものすごくいろんなこと言っては来る
言っては来る メールは来る
私はそれでもうキレさっぱりもう切っちゃったんです
もう返事も何もしないで
電話かけてきたっても
まああと一時間経ってから電話していただけませんかって
私は出ていくんです [笑い]もう電話来るなよとは言わない
私はまあ メールも送るなよとは言わないんで
その代わりに返事はしない
うん  [沈黙]とにかく人間っていうのは体が大事だという態度でいると
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているところはどうせ理解できないんです
健康のために瞑想するということもありますしね
その場合も自分の体こそ宝物で
あの 何て言いますか 何かどこかの宗教で体が神殿だと説明する場合もありますね
だから何て言いますか
清らかな魂が清らかな神殿に宿るんだと
ですから 体はもう健康で保つことが
それこそ修行であると
そうすると勝手に清らかな魂が宿ってくれるという
心落ち着けるということは目的はないのです
その宗教は瞑想です やっているのは
まあ瞑想といえばヨガですね
で ヨガやって とにかく肉体を永遠に綺麗で保つという考えのためで
すごくなかなか分かりにくいんですよ
我々には 仏教の思考を持っている人にとっては分かりにくいんですね
どこか永遠でしょうかと
一秒一秒で体が年取っていくんですけどね
で 細胞も壊れて壊れていくでしょうし
新しく作る細胞を古い細胞ほど立派じゃないでしょう
で そういうことなんですけど
やっぱり体がすごく立派なものであると
清らかな魂が宿る神殿であると
で 自分の体は神殿のごとくと言ったところで
すごく気分が良くなるんですね
わかるんです 意味が あ
なるほど 頑張らなくちゃという
すぐ勇気も出てくる 体が水瓶のようにものすごく不思議でございます
という だからどちらが正しいかという問題なんですけどね
まぁ 大勢の人が正しいという理屈では
大勢の人が言っていることは正しいんです
今まで永遠な命か肉体を持った人は一人もないんだけど
そのことは正しいんです
一人もいないでしょ 死なないでいる人
ずっと昔から一人も証拠はないんだけど
信じるぐらいだったらね
まあそれはいくらでも信じられます
それでこの芸では この瞑想する世界のこと言って
この体っていうのはことは気にしないで
どうせ壊れるもんだから
そちらに対する執着を捨てておくと
心が見えてくるんですよ
そうでない限りは心は見えないんです
腰が痛い この座布団が硬くて
もう瞑想できる気はないとかね
それでずっとこのもうふわふわしている
ものすごいもう柔らかい座布団を作ってあげなくちゃいけない
それでこの綿の上に座るなよとブッダは言ってるんですよ
それでもうすごくこの何て言いますか
このプロセッシングした立派な綿で座るクッションとか作って
その上に座って瞑想したりする
誘った人は一人もいないんですけど
そんなことでは そんなにも自分のお尻は宝物かと
まだまだあの これはまだ言ってくれてないんですね
座る座布団はまあこれなんとかベルベットとかね
そういう高価な絹のようなもので作って
中には随分柔らかい綿を入れて
これは金で宝石散りばめている
台座に入れてくれなきゃダメやとかね
でないと私は瞑想しないしないぞと
そこまでは言ってはまだないんです
これから言うでしょうと思います
期待して待っています
で まぁちょっと痛くなっただけでも
まぁこれで瞑想間違っていると
足がちょっと痛くなると瞑想間違ってる
これ大変なことであると
言うと私も本当に真っ赤な顔をして聞いてあげなくちゃいけない
なぜかというと 人間の足って今までいまだかつて痛くなったことはないでしょう
ずっと日本の文化っていうのはね
普通床で座る文化でしょうし
でも足が痛くなった覚えに覚えないでしょ
これで瞑想に座っちゃうと足が痛いんだからこれ驚くでしょ
腰が痛くなったことはないし
熱くなったことはないし
ちょっと体痙攣みたいな
ちょっとビリビリした経験も超も何もないんだからね
すごいことですよ だから
いかに我々は体に対して執着しているのかと
そこでまあ ちょっと朝早く起こしちゃうと一日中寝るんですね
それで昼間は文句言うんですね
これを睡眠不足やと 要するにそれはしょうがないんですと言いますけどね
日本人は一度も朝早く起きたことないんですよ
みんなちゃんと九時半になると寝て
八時ぐらいに起きる人間ですね
普通は日常生活では 私は一緒に生活したことがないんだからわからない
知らないのは なんでこのずーっと夜一時半まで二時まで電車が走っているのかとかね
コンビニはなんで二十四時間やっているのかとかね
私はもう時々三時とかという時間で見てみたら
もうその時ですよ 繁盛しているのはコンビニなんかは随分人がいるんです
あれって有利ですかね
で だから贅沢言わ文句言おうってのはキリがないんですよ
ちょっと実況中継しなさいとね
ちょっと体をゆっくり動かせと
言うと どこまで言われるのかと
だからそもそもなんで来るのかという疑問もあるんですけど
だからそちら辺で何か見えるのかというと
この俗世間の思考と仏陀の思考のこのどれほど違っているのかっていうことなんです
だから ちょっとのんびりゆっくり体を動かすっていうことはものすごい難しい
しかし 気功だったら もう何千人でもやる
その場合でも ものすごい変な動きでもうスローで動いてますけど
だからテレビで見る場合はもうまるっきり逆なんですね
心を整えて呼吸を整える
呼吸を整えて体を直すという感じ
仏教はもう逆で体を使ってそこから呼吸やら整えて体を忘れてしまって心を制するという
心を制するところを目的にする場合は
これを認めないんですね
世界は体を制する方に行っちゃうと
まあすごくOKっていう風になるんです
正反対ですよ 中国の思考と仏教の思考っていうのは
で 汚いところは全部仏教から学んだものなんです
あれ中国で開発したものじゃありません
で 四千年のくだらん何とかじゃないんです
ただ 臭い餃子にしても
テレビで宣伝すると もうもう六千年の伝統の餃子とか言うでしょうに
うん だから決まり文句はずっと言い合ってるんです
食い物だったら まあそんなことで
で そんなすごいことかわからないんですけど
まあいろいろ方法っていうのは
まあ仏教から言ったものなんですけどね
この気功っていうのはまあロクなものじゃないんですよ
別に あれはこの あの 体はゆっくりこの流れ
あの引力ありますね 引力も物質的エネルギーなんです
だからずっと体にあの
そのエネルギーは入ってるんです
だからそこで地水火風の地の働きが動いてるんです
それで我々のは体重があって
重さがあって 地球から離れない状態にべったり付いてるんです
そこでこの その引力に合わせて体を動かすと結構楽なんです
そこであの水火風の働きもあるんだなということはなんとなくわかって経験するんです
これですよ このすごいことやってるの
だからこの私たちのは 1分でできるんです
気功ではまあかなり時間かかりますけど
できてものすごいくだらないと思ってるんです
できないわけじゃないんです
で 体をすごい軽く感じると思ったらすごい簡単にできるんです
ほんのわずかなほんの瞬間の時間で
ものすごい強烈な重くやってなってなるぞと思ったらこれもできますけどね
何のことないんですよ
地風火風のエネルギーのそれぞれに集中するだけ
集中するのに時間かかるわけないでしょうに
重さに集中するか 動きに集中するか
どちらかなんです 重さに集中した時点ですぐ地でしょうし
体が硬くなっちゃうんです
それで 動きに集中しちゃうと風でしょうし
軽くなるんです それは物理的に硬くなる
軽くなるってこととまるっきり関係ないんです
なぜかというと 我々は心で意識して生きてるんだから
で 例えば外から情報入らなく
目が見えなくなって 耳が聞こえなくなって
例えば一時的に五根も停止したと思ってください
目も耳も鼻も口も全部五根も瞬間停止しちゃうと
もう世界存在しないでしょう
だから自分が何を認識することかということで
それだけの話で それで客観的な世界その通りという話でもないんです
そんなの難しい話だから置いておいて
まあ一応体が水瓶のように壊れる
えーと まあどうでもいいっていうことで
どうせ壊れるものだから
ということで 心が見えてくる
心が見えてくる 心っていうのはもう大変なんです
これはもう街そのものみたいで
何がないかとわからないぐらいなんです
心の中に 街だから 城壁に囲まっているところだから全部揃っている
というか 何でもありきでしょうに
王様も住んでいて 大臣たちもいて
で 売春宿までやると それでもうものすごい汚くて病気になって
もうそういう人々の街
ホームレスもいて 乞食もいて
街っていうのはそういうものなんです
そこでアル中やら麻薬中毒やらそういう連中もいて
それでスリやら強盗やらやってる人々も街にいるんです
街といえば大変なんです
そうはイメージ出てこないでしょうね
だからそれは私は知ったことではないんですけど
街といえばそういう風に思ってみてください
一時的でも なんて素晴らしい
世界一素晴らしいということじゃないんです
東京すごい街だと パリなんかは死ぬ前に一回だけでも行ってみたいんだとかね
そこそこではそう思ってますよ
一生一回だけでもパリに行って
あのエッフェル塔を登って
そこで写真ちょっとこうやってピースをする写真を撮って
それではもう死んでも悔いがないという
パリっていうのはそんな街ですかね
私相手は何かないと思いますかね
あれで 高くて値段が高くて食えないんですよ
ほとんど食べるも食い物もなく飢えさせてるんです
何かちょっとしたパンちょっと食べて
それも外で そこで喫茶店にあるそういうところでウェイトレスとかでそういう人がいるんですけど
給料はないんです ただお願いして仕事をするんです
そこでコーヒー飲んだ人が何かチップをあげるんですよね
それが給料なんです うん
だからまあ そこであっちこっち立ってる女性の方々も至る所にいる
それまた仕事なんです
それでまた画家もいるんですよ
音楽家もいるんです それで音楽家
画家 芸術家たちもみんな群がるところだから
あの連中の生活は大変大変
あれで面白くないでしょうね
あちらで誰かがストリートパフォーマンスですごい立派なことをやって
こちらでまたそれ一両だ
あちらも一両 あちらも一両
だから金が入らないんです
こちらで誰かが絵を描いて売ろうと思ったっても
これなかなか腕がものすごい一人前ですけど
ちょっと散歩歩いたらまたまた一人
これで食えると思いますかね
それで能力の多すぎんたちもいる
で ひどい病気にかかって苦しんでる人もいる
それでスリもいる 何でもあり
東京にしても同じこと
美しいだけじゃないんです
東京といえばものすごい立派な方々
ほとんどほとんど住んでいる
で また恐ろしい人々も住んでいる
麻薬売買も東京でやっている
そういうことで この 大体ホームレスはもうどこに住んでますかね
田舎には一人も住んでないでしょ
釣り強盗とか 田舎でやってる強盗っていうのはなんとかというと面白いんですよ
あの なんとかシャベルカーみたいな車持ってきて
あれでそのままチェーンで大胆にこれ引っ張って
それで破って金を持って帰ると
話聞いただけでも面白いんで
泥棒するんだったら大胆にやるぞと
それでも誰がやったか見つからないというところはさらに面白いんです
それは世界一優秀な警察ですから
見つかりくはないです
自分で自白しない限りは
まあそんな世界ですよ
街っていうのはね  [背景音楽]